we're creating barbecue style beef
brisket with crunchy coleslaw and sweet
potato wedges which will be right up her
Street Holly now you love barbecues
right so you gonna help me barbecue this
delicious piece of brisket brisket okay
beautiful was a very tough cut of meat
so needs to be cooked slowly so it gets
really nice and tender outside we're
gonna actually put the barbecue flavor
on there but we're gonna cook it in the
oven
okay so mustard powder okay yeah we have
some celery seed next a little bit of
salt in there okay what's this here
cumin to again nice good now this one
can pepper nicely right right two
teaspoons of that hidden as well good
now all you to do fresh pepper on there
I'll give that a little mix little
sleeves and then I want you to rub all
that spice into the brisket almost like
you're massaging in there good girl John
holes get your hands nice and flat on
there good girl
now that's nice and coated okay in the
spice so gas on roasting tray Oh what we
got to do now with all those spices is
sear them in couple of tablespoons of
olive oil into the tray
well then house getting nice and hot now
and get your brisket and all that spice
they let in there nicely okay so now
we'll start coloring it as you start to
sear in you smell those spices yep all
that spice left on the plate
we're gonna use yeah I want you to get
the onions nice and carefully slice them
down not too thin but just like you're
chopping them take your time smell all
those spices now
good go thank you Sam
Holly what's homework that bad don't rub
your eyes don't rub your eyes we've got
the color look on the brisket okay yeah
take that out
literary for 30 seconds okay I'm using
the tray please
nice you see a star just smells funny
barbecue you already give that a little
stir
nice now one nice tablespoon of brown
sugar for the brown sugar
you'll start caramelizing the onions
right from there my Bailey's in please
good girl yes please
rice will take over Kevin that tray is
very very hot a tablespoon of tomato
puree roast that off at the bottom of
the tray will you rub it in amongst the
onions good girl now look at the colors
onions right now time for little drink
at the brisket okay one bottle of Ian
please
so you go in you put yours in there I'll
put my hair good health to you and your
brisket good health bring that to the
ball okay now this is where it gets
really exciting I want you to lift the
brisket up and put it on top of the
onions and she goes good girl and then I
want you to pour the stock all the way
around please I'm using beef stock but
it will work with chicken stock or even
vegetable stock once the stock has come
to the boil cover tightly with foil
you're just pinching the ends
spend that down and then you just twist
all the way so that's nice and tight
that's the hard work done simply pop it
in the oven for three and a half hours
and as it cooks and get on with the side
dishes first job sweet potato wedges
with some serious flavor start by making
a spice mix in a dry pan toast coriander
seeds until beautifully aromatic then
put them in a pestle and mortar add salt
and grind next smoked paprika dried
oregano cayenne pepper and mix spice mix
done now simply cut your sweet potatoes
into wedges toss in olive oil and
thoroughly cover with the spice mix onto
a baking tray and into a preheated oven
for 30 minutes turning half way
irresistible sweet potato wedges are
ready now to finish off my beef see that
smell just sort of travels everywhere
[Music]
now look at that so we can leave that to
rest is resting really resting means
where you cooked a joint and you just
leave it to relax so I make the meat so
much more tender okay right coleslaw
traditionally you would mix slaw with
what that's right mayonnaise this time
we do a little different Saturday to put
the yogurt into the bowl for me please
all of it I'll start slicing the white
cabbage and the red cabbage now from
there a nice tablespoon of mustard in
there please give that a nice mix up
nice little touch of salt and pepper
okay now a little cider vinegar so
little splash of cider vinegar in there
okay as I just read this okay I'd like
you please then to get the red cabbage
and just open up into that and mix it in
at the same time and then you fold that
in there as I start reading see how it's
coming together
yeah nice that's all the red cabbage now
the white so got that nice vinegary
tartness for the slaw and the yogurt
keeps it nice and fresh a little bit in
one more little thing so there's some
nice chopped fresh chives in there and
that will give you this nice light onion
flavor so chose in house that now taste
it with the chives in there mmm
delicious so I would like you to fill up
the bowl and very carefully lift out my
brisket it's been in the oven for nearly
three and a half hours so it's been
cooked slowly that sits on there oh my
goodness me let me just show you what
this looks like
I start slicing it you'll see how soft
look at that and here's the thing about
helping daddy cook here's the perk you
get to taste it first for anybody that
tastes delicious see all that wonderful
flavor in their last job is to create an
incredibly quick and delicious sauce
guess on and reduce the spicy juices and
onions at the beef cooked in then add in
cider vinegar and you had a brilliant
tangy barbecue sauce Wow
it's brisket and a half now the rest of
it can go in the gravy pot that's a
really nice rich spicy barbecue onion
gravy that my darling is the perfect way
to serve brisket right you ready if you
carry the sweet potato for me I've got
the brisket Wow